merci la parole est à présent à
Catherine de roche pour le groupe
UMP merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues Isabelle
Lebret l'a dit le précédent gouvernement
avait engagé une réflexion sur le sujet
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui ont confiant
à cette fin une mission conseiller des
tâches à Richard il s'agissait de
réfléchir au devenir du scrutin prudomal
pour les raisons qui viennent d'être
énoncées le coût qu'on estime à 100
millions d'euros et surtout le taux
record d'abstention alors certes
modifier le mode de désignation
actuellement d'affaiblir l'institution
pourraient la renforcer puisque les
conseillers prud'homo seraient davantage
représentatifs du vote des salariés mais
encore faudrait-il après concertation
débattre de la question pour savoir s'il
faut aménager les élections pour demain
ou les remplacer par un autre dispositif
vous souhaitez le supprimer et acter le
principe d'un dispositif reposant sur la
représentativité désorganisation
paritaires dans un projet de loi annoncé
en urgence or votre proposition est pour
le moment assez vas même si vous venez
de répondre à plusieurs questions et ce
qui a confirmé l'ensemble des questions
qui ont pu te poser par les collègues
sur différents bancs pour ma part je
m'interroge sur la destination des
sommes qui seraient économisées et ce
sera l'objet de ma question alors comme
je l'ai déjà dit la suppression des
élections prud'homales permettrait
d'économiser 100 millions d'euros c'est
vrai que ce n'est pas une somme
considérable mais néanmoins et
utile actuellement tout ce qui peut ou
réduire le déficit public ou contribuer
à relancer notre productivité comme
l'annonce et mardi le président de la
République or douce d'or c'est déjà il
me semble vous avez déclaré vouloir
rediriger cette somme vers le
financement des organisations syndicales
et patronales plus précisément d'après
les informations dont nous disposons
vous comptez remplacer les crédits
provenants actuellement de la formation
soit 60 millions d'euros par d'autres
sources de financement dont on fera
partie les économies réalisées au moyen
de la suppression des élections pour
demain ce dispositif appelle plusieurs
questions combien d'argent gouvernement
va-t-il réserver pour maintenir à
l'identique le financement des
organisations syndicales sachant que ce
financement sera également assuré par
des cotisations des employeurs quelle
somme souhaitez-vous récupérer sachant
que les élections que de mal n'avaient
lieu que tous les 5 ans ou s'agira-t-il
d'un financement identique vous avez
parlé en effet d'une augmentation des
fonds alloués alors que l'État doit
faire des économies je vous remercie
Monsieur Michel Sapin
le président merci Madame sénatrice pour
cette question je retiendrai le seul
aspect qui touche au cou de son
organisation et que qu'allez-vous faire
en quelque sorte me posez-vous comme
question de ces 100 millions je n'ai pas
insisté outre mesure sur le coup
lui-même parce que je pense que à lui
seul ce coup ne justifierait pas de
prendre une décision de cette nature
j'ajouterai que le coût 100 millions
pour l'État ça c'est l'organisation
elle-même doit être cumulée avec le coup
pour chacune des organisations
syndicales qui est tout à fait
considérable et considéré comme tel par
ces organisations syndicales elles-mêmes
c'est peut-être aussi une des raisons
compte tenu la faible audience ensuite
en termes de participation pour laquelle
les organisations syndicales dans leur
majorité sont favorables à une évolution
du mode de scrutin madame la sénatrice
nous aurons à débattre des nouvelles
modalités de financement dans la
transparence la plus totale des
organisations et total et syndical
puisque les nouvelles modalités seront
dans le texte que je vous proposerai et
qui sera adopté en conseil des ministres
la semaine prochaine et nous donnerons à
discuter dans les semaines qui viennent
donc nous aurons dans ce débat toutes
les éléments qui permettront de
connaître très précisément les nouvelles
modalités transparentes de financement
de ces diverses organisations car le
dialogue social le paritarisme mérite le
soutien de l'argent soit des entreprises
soit de l'argent public l'objectif est
évidemment de d'utiliser la majeure
partie des sommes considérées pour venir
renforcer oui renforcer les moyens des
organisations syndicales ou patronales
dans un cadre de transparence totale
l'objectif du financement transparent
n'est pas de diminuer les moyens de ces
organisations il est leur permettre là
aussi dans un souci de renforcer leur
légitimité de leur donner des moyens
pour faire la part d'intérêt général qui
leur revient dans le cas de la gestion
du paritarisme et de leur action au
niveau régional ou au niveau national
donc quelle est la destination elle ira
mais nous en parlerons très dans le
détail au fond qui viendra financer
l'ensemble de la vie paritaire
organisation patronale et syndicale
elles permettra donc de renforcer ainsi
leurs moyens chers
autre rapidement pour dire en effet que
nous entendons donc ce texte avec
impatience nous grattons de ce fait que
qu'il faille statuer en urgence
justement sur sur ce texte et surtout
on voit bien au fil des questions qui
restent encore beaucoup d'interrogations
sur sur le le les élections prud'homales
et le fait de statut par ordonnance ne
nous convient pas bon on voit bien que
le les droits du Parlement dans ce dans
ce cas-là sont un petit peu réduits et
c'est quand même contraire à ce que nous
avait promis le candidat François
Hollande merci la parole est à présent
la dernière ouatrice gisais le prince
pour le groupe socialiste alors monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues